[Music]
if Ronnie gets any closer to this girl
he's about to have a second baby mama
there was a blonde girl with Ronnie
nobody's watching what really happened
the cast of Jersey Shore weighing in on
Ronnie's cheating scandal on the show
the drama that's unfolded since and his
future it seems like Ronnie's really
struggling though what is going on think
it's cool about a show it's gonna show
us real life like going through some
real life things you can't deal with
some temptations in Miami how we dealt
with those people do they just don't
document on TV so it's just do you think
maybe I mean I'm sure you guys have seen
the news and headlines but you should
take a break from filming do you think
it's at that yeah I can't get it with us
so you know there might be something we
really do stuff to go yes
as his friends even without the show and
the cameras rolling like how have you
been there to support him return to give
their small advice and we're proud of
him so I were excited you guys to see
exactly some steps that he decided to
take what do you make of him and Genesis
right now we support him who support
them we love them and to see how
everything plays out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]